[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
parce que la culture est un axe
important et c'est pas non plus
par hasard si ce festival a lieu pendant
les vacances scolaires
le fait de venir voir des spectacles et
de faire de la culture et devoirs de la
culture c'est quelque chose qui est
complémentaire à l'école voilà c'est pas
opposé et le toto table c'est la
huitième édition cette année sur cette
volonté de démocratisation de la culture
parce qu'il faut pas oublier que les
spectacles sont toujours à des prix très
bas il ya six représentations
proposition donc dont sa réunionnaise et
le tarif est de 6 euros
et si on prend le pass de la journée
c'est à 5 euros mais tout âge confondu
et les ateliers il y en a huit au total
et les les ateliers et les jeux sont
gratuits
parce qu'il est aussi important à un
moment donné que ceux qui n'ont pas
forcément la possibilité de voir un
spectacle puisse pouvoir être présent
avec nous et de se mélanger à tout le
monde et c'est vraiment un axe vraiment
très fort pour moi
nous faisons aussi des représentations
scolaires et c'est quand même plus de
huit représentations qui seront
réservées aux scolaires puisque sergio
grondin ya bête
jamie adkins et mounawar et fred tess
offrons des représentations pour destiné
au jeune public et aux enfants des
écoles et des collèges
[Musique]
oui l'occasion est prêt donc la survenue
en août au total nous les sourds parce
que dana un peu à entre 500 600
marmaille toute la journée
il convient peut pas tout l'après midi
des halles ou comment ça arrive depuis
une heure et demie 13h45 pour continuer
à manger des crêpes parce que la pagaie
manger le dessert
le premier spectacle est à 14 heures
ensuite le deuxième à 16 heures et le
dernier à 18 heures et pendant tout
l'après midi
on peut aller faire de la musique avec
des instruments faits à partir
d'éléments de récupération il ya nos
joues avec ses petites voitures les jeux
lontan
il ya les ateliers de dessin il y à la
bibliothèque éphémère ce très beau
partenariat avec la bibliothèque
départementale qui à un moment aussi de
repos et partagent avec les parents
c'est les new gravity qui font un
atelier de parcours c'est que ça encore
une année notamment à fait me rappelle
puis d'ampli mois voilà ça bouillonne de
partout est dedans et dehors et c'est ça
le plus important
[Musique]
à
pink qui sait